brasil superó los 120 mil muertos por
kobe 19 y el número de contagios se
acerca a los 4 millones aunque las
cifras diarias han empezado a
estabilizarse en medio de este panorama
el presidente jair bolsonaro quien
padeció y ya superó el virus continúa
promoviendo las aglomeraciones durante
su visita al estado de goiás al
mandatario se le vio sin mascarilla y
estrechando la mano de sus seguidores en
esta ocasión volvió a defender el uso de
la cloroquina como tratamiento contra el
coronavirus aunque su eficacia no ha
sido comprobada el pulso entre su
administración y los gobiernos estatales
no se detiene
sigue negando que el virus es grave que
no es una pandemia que necesitamos usar
mascarilla promueve la aglomeración no
usa desinfectante de manos no hace
ninguna recomendación de distanciamiento
condena el aislamiento e incluso
promueve la hidroxi cloroquina illinois
lo lamento
sao paulo es el estado más golpeado por
el cobe 19 en brasil su gobernador dijo
que están listos para garantizar la
vacuna en este territorio en caso de que
el gobierno dé bolsonaro les dé la
espalda con miles de voluntarios en esta
y otros estados brasil también se ha
convertido en un epicentro mundial de
ensayos de vacunas entre ellas las
fabricadas por la universidad de oxford
y astrazéneca así como la desarrollada
por la alemana vio en tec y la
estadounidense pfizer
[Música]